The ever-changing cast of "House of
the Dragon" can be hard to pin down,
so here's a handy guide to all the new
Targaryen offspring — blonde and otherwise.
Thanks to a ten year time jump in the sixth
episode, entitled "The Princess and the Queen,"
a big chunk of the cast is now all grown
up, and they've all got kids of their own.
"Ugh. You are nearly a man grown, how
is it that you can be so short-sighted?"
Considering that "House of the Dragon" has
already been renewed for a second season and
promises to bring viewers through the entirety of
the Targaryen civil war known as the Dance of the
Dragons, these kids will, with absolute certainty,
play enormous roles in the infighting to come.
That said, it can be tough to parse which children
belong to whom or how and why they might even be
important. So who are the Targaryen offspring that
we need to know about, and why do they matter?
"This is the stuff, Lyonel!"
As the sixth episode kicks off, Rhaenyra is
deep in the throes of childbirth with her third
son — whom her husband surprise-christens
"Joffrey", after his dead lover — but
the ones who really matter right now are
Jacaerys and Lucarys, aka Jace and Luke.
Introduced when they meet their baby
brother, there's one thing instantly
noticeable about these two boys:
they don't have platinum blonde hair,
while their parents, born of Houses
Targaryen and Velaryon, definitely do.
Anyone who remembers Ned Stark muttering
"Baratheon, black of hair" in the first
season of "Game of Thrones" probably knows
where this storyline is going. Turns out,
considering Laenor, well, doesn't bat
for Rhaenyra's team, she outsourced her
childbearing years to Ser Harwin Strong, Captain
of the City Watch and a confirmed brunette.
"Do keep trying, Ser Laenor. Sooner or
later, you may get one who looks like you."
All that said, Rhaenyra's children are definitely
Targaryens. In the episode, Jacaerys works on
training his dragon, Vermax, who's quite young
but is already responding well to his commands.
Lucarys is still quite young, but it's mentioned
that his traditional Targaryen dragon egg hatched
in his crib as well, so it stands to reason that
both brothers will be on dragonback soon enough.
Far away from their cousins in King's
Landing, Baela and Rhaena — who seem to
be named for their Targaryen ancestor
Baelon as well as Laena's mother
Rhaenys — are stranded with their parents
Laena Velaryon and Prince Daemon Targaryen.
Though they lead a seemingly peaceful
and bountiful life out in Pentos,
the girls dream of more. In one
scene in "The Princess and the
Queen," Rhaena laments not having a dragon
egg from birth as her sister Baela does,
while Laena reassures her that
she'll go on to be a rider someday.
However, these two young girls are struck
by tragedy when their mother Laena, in labor
with their younger brother, encounters
complications that can't be overcome.
"I've reached the limit of my art."
Laena opts to burn herself and the burgeoning
baby alive with the help of her dragon Vhagar,
leaving her daughters alone with their father
Daemon. These two girls may be motherless,
but they have Velaryon and Targaryen blood
in their veins, unlike Rhaenyra's children.
The blondest children on the show thus far,
Aegon II, Aemond, and Helaena are the issue
of Alicent and her much-older husband,
Rhaenyra's father King Viserys. Blessed
with the icy hair of the Targaryen family, their
parentage doesn't stand in doubt for a second,
and upon Aegon's birth, there's a bit of
a kerfuffle over the line of succession.
Despite previously naming Rhaenyra
as his official heir, Aegon's mere
existence places King Viserys in a bind. The
Seven Kingdoms may not accept a female ruler,
and with a male heir at long last, it might make
more sense to put Aegon on the throne. Viserys
sticks by his daughter, but as he ages,
it's clear that his wife has other plans.
"The Princess and the Queen" is the first
glimpse we get of Aegon as an older child, and,
honestly? He's kind of a jerk. He
bullies his younger brother Aemond
by giving him a pig instead of a dragon
and fights dirty during his training,
showing himself to be pretty
smug and largely insufferable.
By contrast, Aemond and Helaena have
shown themselves to be much quieter.
Helaena seems to like playing with centipedes,
while poor Aemond just wants to follow
in his family's massive footsteps.